overnight the State Department ordered
all non-emergency US Embassy and
consulate employees in Iraq to leave
that follows rising tensions with Iran
Iraq sniper President Trump dismissed a
report that his national security team
is reviewing a plan for more than
100,000 US troops to confront Iran David
Martin is at the Pentagon where
officials suspect the Iranians are
behind sabotage attacks on oil tankers
news this morning David good morning
good morning in addition to ordering all
diplomatic personnel all non-essential
diplomatic personnel out of Baghdad the
u.s. is also warning all Americans that
it is too dangerous to travel to Iraq
president Trump touted at a campaign
rally what is becoming one of the
hallmarks of his America first foreign
policy we're now holding dangerous
regimes accountable by denying them oil
revenue to fund their corruption
oppression and terror but Iran remains
dangerous US officials say it is highly
likely Iran's Islamic Revolutionary
Guards were responsible for Sunday's
attacks that blew holes in the halls of
Saudi and Norwegian tankers anchored
just outside the Persian Gulf Iranian
combat divers are believed to have
attached explosives to the hall but an
Arab diplomat told CBS News further
investigation is needed and Secretary of
State Pompeo was unwilling to publicly
blame the Iran I don't have anything to
add concrete about the connection
between the actions and
I think in the coming hours and days
we'll know the answer tonight the US has
already sent an aircraft carrier and
b-52 bombers to the Persian Gulf but
president Trump denied reported plans to
send as many as 120,000 more troops
would I do that absolutely but we have
not planned for that and if we did that
would send a hell of a lot more troops
than that on Capitol Hill Virginia
Democratic senator Tim Kaine blasted the
president's thinking it would be Iran
has vehemently denied any involvement in
the attacks and accused President Trump
of playing a very dangerous game risking
devastating war gale all right David
Martin reporting from Washington thank
you